From Hannibal's tastiest meal preps
to Slippin' Jimmy's messiest exploits,
these shows are proof that some TV prequels are
even better than the stories they came from.
A prequel to a reboot, Caprica hit screens in
2010, a year after the dramatic ending of science
fiction drama Battlestar Galactica. Battlestar had
been a relaunch of a short-lived sci-fi adventure
from 1978, with producer Ronald D. Moore turning
the campy family adventure into a gritty war
story that dazzled audiences with dark, sobering
storylines and unpredictable twists and turns.
Caprica was entirely different: a sci-fi political
thriller set decades earlier on a thriving world
where A.I. technology is in its infancy. Taking
place nearly 60 years before the Earth/Cylon war
of BSG, the show explored the relationship between
two rival families, the Graystones and the Adamas,
and saw the advent of the technology
that would lead to the Cylon race.
"I'm Zoe. And the avatar. And the robot. Like
some kind of whatchacallit three-parter."
"Trinity."
Starring Eric Stoltz and Esai Morales as family
patriarchs Daniel Graystone and Joseph Adama,
respectively, the series set itself apart from BSG
with a focus on political and religious
intrigue and profound personal drama.
"What would you do if you had the
chance to be with your daughter again?"
Packed with social allegory, Caprica garnered rave
reviews from critics. The
Guardian called the series:
"Dense and intelligent sci-fi [...]
complex, bizarre and ambitious."
Despite the acclaim, Caprica
lasted just a single season,
but it's remained a cult favorite ever since.
A Batman prequel arrived in 2014
in the form of Gotham, a grim,
hard-boiled crime series set in the
city Batman would one day protect.
"Bruce. My name is Bruce Wayne."
In it, Bruce Wayne is a young boy, so the series
focuses more on Gotham PD Lieutenant James Gordon,
played by Ben McKenzie, and his efforts
to combat the city's criminal underworld.
The series opened with the killing of
Gotham socialites Thomas and Martha Wayne.
As the show progressed, audiences met
many of Batman's eventual rogues' gallery,
with future villains the Penguin, Catwoman,
the Riddler, and the Joker making appearances,
as well as several new baddies like
Jada Pinkett Smith as Fish Mooney.
"Only my friends call me Fish."
Praised for its slick production and stylish
storytelling, Gotham ran for five seasons,
ending with a now-adult Bruce Wayne donning
cape and cowl to become the Dark Knight.
The Big Bang Theory was a multi-camera
sitcom about three geeky friends in
Pasadena who fill their days with
video games, comic books, and RPGs.
"It's just some quantum mechanics with a
little string theory doodling around the
edges. That part there? That's just a joke. It's
a spoof of the Bourne-Oppenheimer approximation."
A smash hit for 12 astonishing seasons, Big
Bang became a franchise in 2017 with the
debut of prequel series Young Sheldon, about
the awkward youth of child prodigy Sheldon.
Young actor Iain Armitage plays Sheldon,
whose trials and tribulations include
skipping four grades. This makes him a
social misfit and yet, occasionally, a hero
"Him being so young isn't like weird?"
"I'm basically fifty."
"And we're basically 12, so it all works out."
Balancing a tough school
schedule with problems at home,
he also has to deal with the frustrations
of having a dimmer-witted older brother.
"Morning. I slept in the nude last
night. Felt every little breeze."
A heartfelt and heartwarming family sitcom
that brings a fresh angle to the character
with stories about Sheldon's social struggles,
Young Sheldon was a big hit, with IndieWire
calling out its strong mix of comedy and drama and
its empathetic approach to the central character.
Perry Mason began in the 1930s as a series of
novels by Erle Stanley Gardner before becoming
a series of films, a radio drama, and eventually
a hit TV series starring Raymond Burr that ran for
nearly 300 episodes beginning in 1957. Revived
briefly in the 1970s as The New Perry Mason,
Burr returned to the role for a series of
TV movies all the way through the 1990s.
"No further questions."
After a decades-long absence, the
unflappable lawyer reappeared in
the 2020 prequel series Perry
Mason, starring Matthew Rhys.
"You were in the war, weren't you?
The way you hold your cigarette,
hiding the ember in your palm."
"I guess I'm still trying not to
give them something to shoot at."
The series takes place years before Mason
becomes a lawyer. In this darker drama,
Mason is a beleaguered private investigator
whose business is struggling during the
Great Depression. The series' first season
tells a single story across eight episodes,
as Mason investigates a grisly child murder case.
The show's strongest asset
might be its phenomenal cast,
which includes Tatiana Maslany and John
Lithgow, among many other standouts.
Praised for its sophisticated story, compelling
mystery, evocative style, and overall panache,
Perry Mason built off decades of previous
stories to provide a new spin on an old classic.
Born from the mind of Muppets creator Jim
Henson, The Dark Crystal was an iconic '80s
family fantasy film full of ancient relics
and mystical powers. It became an enduring
cult classic thanks to its incredible design,
captivating story, and blend of light-hearted
playfulness with a foreboding sense of doom.
Though there was talk of a sequel for years,
a prequel eventually materialized: The
Dark Crystal: The Age of Resistance.
Released in 2019 as a Netflix original, the series
was helmed by action director Louis Leterrier,
and boasted an all-star cast voicing its
ensemble of puppet actors, including Mark Hamill,
Taron Egerton, Awkwafina, Jason
Isaacs, and Helena Bonham Carter.
"These are the world's greatest
puppeteers working with Louis Leterrier,
a brilliant director. It's a look
that you've never seen before."
Set long before the events of the film,
Age of Resistance sees a group of childlike
Gelflings on a journey to unite their people
to fight back against the devious and
tyrannical Skeksis that rule them.
The series delivered a powerful
story of friendship, loyalty,
and indomitable spirit. Gorgeously produced with
sumptuous visuals and a story that expanded on
Henson's original. The Dark Crystal: Age
of Resistance was a magical treat that did
more than justice to a classic, making for
a stellar fantasy series in its own right.
Director Peter Jackson's groundbreaking
Lord of the Rings trilogy brought J.R.R.
Tolkien's fantasy world to the mainstream in the
early 2000s. Expertly realized with a lavish
production budget, it quickly became iconic.
"Always remember, Frodo. The ring is trying to
get back to its master. It wants to be found."
Following a trilogy of prequels adapted from The
Hobbit, many wondered where the franchise would go
next, but it would be a decade before Amazon's
Rings of Power prequel series landed in 2022.
Rings of Power is set in the Second Age of Middle
Earth, long before the events of Lord of the
Rings, yet includes several crossover characters,
notably immortal elves Elrond and Galadriel. As
new evil rises in the East, the different races —
Dwarves, Elves, Hobbits, and Man — prepare to rise
up and meet it head-on. The series is a visual
treat, a true spectacle that brings the cinematic
experience to the small screen. Story-wise,
it expands upon themes from Jackson's trilogy.
Strong performances, an intriguing plot,
and plenty of surprises have helped it garner
critical acclaim, too, with Variety calling it:
"A perfectly winning adaptation that
unfolds swashbuckling adventures with
clear reverence and affection for
the considerable mythos behind it."
A massive success for the streaming giant, it's
anyone's guess where the series will go following
its debut season, but it's already proven
itself a worthy addition to Tolkien's world.
In 2001, the comedy troupe known as "The
State" produced an offbeat comedy film,
Wet Hot American Summer, that followed
the antics of a group of teen counselors
at a 1980s summer camp. Members of "The
State" were joined by a remarkable cast,
including young Paul Rudd, Bradley Cooper,
and Amy Poehler alongside veterans David
Hyde Pierce, Molly Shannon, and Janeane
Garofalo. Though it flopped in theaters,
its surreal humor and raunchy tone made it a
cult classic. More than a decade later in 2015,
a prequel series arrived on Netflix, Wet
Hot American Summer: First Day of Camp.
The entire cast — now 15 years older — returned,
still playing teenagers in a story set several
months before the film, on the first day of
camp in 1981. Even Rudd, Cooper, and Poehler,
who had since achieved megastardom,
came back for the eight-episode series,
with the likes of Kristin Wiig and
Jason Schwartzman joining them.
Lauded by critics for its wild, off-the-wall
comedy, the show became a big hit for Netflix. In
2017, it was followed by a sequel series,
Wet Hot American Summer: Ten Years Later.
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho was
a seminal 1960s thriller that
almost single handedly gave rise to the
modern psychological horror genre. Psycho
centers on a young woman who winds
up in a hotel run by Norman Bates,
a twisted madman whose obsession with
his own mother turns him into a killer.
"Well, a boy's best friend is his mother."
A Hollywood classic and box-office smash, it was
followed by a few lesser sequels and a TV movie
called Bates Motel in 1987. In 2013, when the
title was repurposed for a prequel television
series starring Freddie Highmore as a young
Norman, no one had particularly high hopes.
The series introduces a teenaged Norman,
whose mother Norma, played by Vera Farmiga,
purchases a motel after the death of her
husband. Trouble strikes when Norma is
forced to kill an attacker, leading to a
series of cover-ups and conspiracies that
threaten to expose them both. Surrounded
by violence, Norman's fragile mental state
deteriorates. As he slowly spirals into madness,
his mother struggles to deal with his condition.
Bates Motel is a riveting psychological
thriller that ran for five seasons.
"You told her something happens
to me when I black out. You said
I change. That I'm not myself. Who am
I, Mother? Who am I and what do I do?"
The final season was a jaw-dropping
remake of the original film. The Los
Angeles Times called the series "twisty,
mood[y] [and] modern." Bates Motel is a
blueprint for how to craft a clever,
fresh prequel to an iconic property.
The 1991 film Silence of the
Lambs brought author Thomas
Harris' novel to the big screen with aplomb.
"Oh, Clarice, your problem is you
need to get more fun out of life."
Star Anthony Hopkins gave a spine-chilling — and
Oscar-winning — performance as sociopathic serial
killer Hannibal Lecter. Technically,
this was Lecter's second big-screen
appearance. He originally featured in
Michael Mann's 1986 flick Manhunter.
Danish actor Mads Mikkelsen took on the role
for a 2013 NBC prequel series titled Hannibal,
which chronicled the years before Lecter was
imprisoned for a series of cannibalistic murders.
Drawing mostly on material from Harris' novel
Red Dragon, the show saw renowned psychiatrist
Lecter assisting intrepid FBI agent Will Graham,
played by Hugh Dancy, as a criminal profiler.
"Not fond of eye contact, are you?"
"Eyes are distracting. See
too much. Don't see enough."
Created by Bryan Fuller, the series
reimagined the relationship between
the two future adversaries, as Lecter —
whose murderous inclinations are explored
in secret — becomes obsessed
with the young FBI agent.
"It seems you have an admirer."
"You think someone sent me in
here because they admire me?"
Dark, disturbing, and bold, Hannibal pushed the
boundaries of network censorship and
was rewarded with universal acclaim.
Star Trek had done prequels before, with the
2001 series Enterprise set in the early days
of Starfleet. 2017's Star Trek: Discovery also
takes place in the past, just a decade before Kirk
and Spock. In that show's second season, we meet
Captain Pike and the U.S.S. Enterprise. In 2022,
their story spun off into its own series: Star
Trek: Strange New Worlds. Starring Anson Mount,
Ethan Peck, and Rebecca Romijn as classic
characters Pike, Mr. Spock, and Number One,
it explored early missions of the Enterprise
that had only previously been hinted at.
Joined by a mix of returning
franchise icons like Uhura –
"Oh, can I help?"
"No."
– Nurse Chapel, and Dr. M'Benga, plus new
characters La'an Noonien Singh, Ensign Ortegas,
and Andorian engineer Hemmer, the series was a
retro return to sci-fi adventure. While Star Trek:
Discovery and Star Trek: Picard focused on
darker, more adult-themed serialized stories,
Strange New Worlds successfully recaptured
the classic Trek spirit with family-friendly
episodic stories that took the
crew to new worlds each week.
With a strong cast and a big budget,
the series refreshed the final frontier.
Strange New Worlds was hailed as a return to
form with a stirring mix of big adventure,
thought-provoking science
fiction, humor, and heart.
Creating a spin-off of an acclaimed series
can be risky. No matter how good it is,
it may always live in the shadow of its
parent series. Such was the predicament
when the 16-time Emmy Award-winning Breaking
Bad announced that supporting star Bob Odenkirk
would lead spin-off series, Better Call
Saul. The fact that it would be a prequel
and would run alongside the final seasons
of Breaking Bad, made it even trickier.
"Did you just bring a bomb into a hospital?"
"What? Was I supposed to leave it on his car?"
But Odenkirk and series creator Vince
Gilligan pulled off the impossible.
"What the hell do you think you're doing?"
"I need Saul. I need him right now."
The show, which debuted in 2015, explored more of
unscrupulous lawyer Saul Goodman's shady past and
underhanded dealings, while appearances from
Giancarlo Esposito as Gus Fring and Jonathan
Banks as Mike Ehrmantraut helped flesh out
the Breaking Bad universe by enriching old
stories with new context. In time, the events
of the series caught up with its predecessor,
which even allowed for the brief return
of Bryan Cranston as Walter White.
With a more left-of-center vibe
and a colorful cast of quirky,
eccentric characters, Better Call Saul was
a series with its own identity while still
delivering gut-wrenching, nail-biting crime
stories. Standing on the shoulders of a giant,
the series may have soared even higher, with
The Guardian declaring it even more profound,
and outstripping Gilligan's
former series in nearly every way.